about 30% households in India are yet to
have access to electricity if you want
to provide Alexa tea to everybody we
have to ensure that our electricity is
affordable India it has a vast reservoir
of pool we are probably the third or
fourth largest reservoir of coal in the
world coal is cheap whether you and I
like it or not coal is cheap you have to
think about this from this point of view
if you created the problem in the past
we will create it in the future
we have 700 million households who cook
using biomass today 700 million
households if those households move to
gold you have that much more use of
fossil fuel then the entire world is
fried if anyone gives you this very cute
stuff and tells you all the world's poor
should move to solar and why do they
have to make the mistakes that we have
made I hear this all the time from
American NGOs and I'm like wow you know
I mean if it was that easy I would have
really liked the u.s. to move towards
solar but you haven't let's put our
money where our mouth is we have to
practice what we preach
absolutely I'm sorry to say this I know
you're an American and please don't take
this amiss but your consumption is gonna
really put a hole in the planet and I
think that's the conversation we need to
have